ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE WILL
CONVENE. IT APPEARS THAT WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. WITH THE SECTOR
CALLED THE ROLE FOR THE CORE.
THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE.
COMMENCING. IT APPEARS WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. WITH THE SEPTIC
CALL THE ROLL. FOR THE CURRENT.
DO WE HI. DOT NELSON. NELSON
HERE ALAN. ALLEN HERE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA HERE BAKER. GORGEOUS
WE'RE SUPPOSED FOR JESSE HERE
BRADFORD LATER. GLAZER HERE
WEST L. THEM SOON FORM. THAT'S
WHY SO YOU GOT ANYWHERE SO HERE
JONES THANK YOU JONES HERE CAN
LONGER. MELENDEZ FORTINO
FLORENTINO HERE RUBIO. WELL
WELL HERE WE HAVE A CAR IN
GERMAN WE HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT.
IN RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY THE FACT THAT THE
LEGISLATORS THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
PARTICIPATION IN THESE
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS. AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS OF
SENATORS MADE THE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICE.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE THE ACCESS.
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC
WE WERE ADMITTED MEMBERS TO THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS.
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
PARTICIPATE. THE NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 WITH AN ACCESS
CODE. ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORK.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
DOOR TO THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
A MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE. AND
THEN ZERO. TO INDICATE SUPPORT
OUR OPPOSITION. PRECIOUS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
THE OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE BETTER
SHORTLY. WHAT YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE UNDETERRED. YOU'RE
NOW READY THEN TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY INTO THE VOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING. ON THE HEARING
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. REMEMBER TO MEET.
PICTURE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
PARTICIPATE. I WILL MAINTAIN
THE DECORUM DURING THE HEARING
AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL JUST PROVED TO BE
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING. OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS. WHATEVER
VERSION MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT EVER
HEARING WHICH WAS CLOSED IN THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF THESE ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL OF PATIENT SO ALL
PARTIES. CAN BE HEARD AND FULLY
PARTICIPATE. WE'VE GOT SEVEN
BILLS ON THE AGENDA TODAY. AND
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A FORMAL
READY. WE'RE GOING TO GET WITH
OUR CONSENT ITEMS. AND THEN
MOVE THROUGH THE AGENDA BY LORD.
OUR FIRST DAUGHTER IS ALREADY
HERE. AFTER EACH BILL IS
PRESENTED. THE BILL WILL BE
PLACED ON CALL. AFTER ALL THE
BILLS HAVE BEEN HEARD. THE
CHAIR WILL OPEN THE ROLL CALL
FOR EACH BILL ONCE AGAIN. TWO
DEMETRIA MEMBERSHIP ANOTHER
COMMITTEES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE AND BE RECORDED ON THESE
BILLS. BUT DURING THE DAY
BECAUSE OF THE SELECTED THE
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND TRAINING
PROTOCOLS WHICH GOVERN OUR
PROCEEDINGS. I'M LIMITING THE
TESTIMONY TO EITHER SIDE TWO
MINUTES TOTAL. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
AMERICAN. NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT NEEDS IT IS LIMITED WE
JUST DON'TAPPLY YOURSELF THEN
STATED POSITION. NOT FOR THE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING. THE EIGHT TO
LOSE MEANING THOSE WHO. ARE
GOING TO BE JUST SAYING I'M FOR
I'M AGAINST. WE'RE LIMITING
THEIR WITH TO TEN MINUTES PER
SIDE. WHERE TO MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NOW. THE FOUR
BILLS ON THE CONSENT. THESE ARE
FILING A ONE EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE ITEM. THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
SIX NINE. FIRE ALARM. FOR
EIGHTY NINE FIVE SEVEN. TIELINE
FIVE. EIGHTY ONE TWELVE NINETY
ONE MAY I HAVE. THE MOTION. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR GENDER
ARCHULETA YES MOVE SHOULD. FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WOULD YOU
CHECK CHECK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TODD NELSON
ALL RIGHT NO SIN HI ALAN HI
ALAN HI ARCHULETA. FOR TWO AND
A HALF HI BECKER ALL RIGHT
BAKER HI GORGEOUS- BORDERS HI
BRADFORD BLAZER. HI LATER I
WENT SO. JONES HI JONES HI KEN
LONGER MELENDEZ FORTINO.
FOURTEEN OHIO RUBIO WILL HI
WILL KIND. GERMAN HAS NINE
VOTES NINE VOTES. ALL RIGHT. WE
WILL PLACE THIS BILL FOR THE
CONTRACT TO BUILD ON THE SHIN
FELLER ON PULL. WE WILL NOW
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST AUTHOR.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VILLUPURAM. YOU MAY BEGIN WITH
YOUR FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THREE NINE
WELCOME THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
AB TWO THREE NINE EXPANDS
CALIFORNIA EFFORTS TO REDUCE
CONSUMER WAYS TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF GLASS BOTTLES THEY
MAKE THEIR WAY INTO OUR
LANDFILLS. AT THIS TIME IT
HELPS OR OR SMALL FAMILY
WINERIES REDUCE OVERHEAD COSTS
RELATED TO BUYING NEW BOTTLES.
A. B. TWO THREE THREE NINE
SHOWS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICIES AND BUSINESS FRIENDLY
POLICIES ARE NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS KIM
STEMWARE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE MONTEREY COUNTY DENTURES
GROWERS ASSOCIATION. THANK MR
STEINER ARE YOU THERE.
MODERATOR THANK YOU TERRY AND
I'M WITH. THE MODERATOR. YES
I'M CAN DOWNLOAD THE DIRECTOR
OF THE MONTEREY COUNTY VINTNERS
AND GROWERS CAN WE MARRY MUCH
APPRECIATE BEING IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY TO SHARE AN AMBER. ON
BEHALF OF OUR- NATION THE
DINNER CONTRARY TO MONTEREY
COUNTY AND ALL OF THAT WINE
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU'VE DONE
AND ALL YOU'RE DOING. EIGHT
DURING THESE WILD AND I'M
PRESIDENT AND TRYING TO REACH
YOU. BILL WAS BORN FROM A
QUESTION ONE OF OUR OTHER CHEAP
WINERIES. THE FORMER ABC
DIRECTOR TWO YEARS AGO. GIVEN
OUR DESIRE TO MEET INCREASINGLY
SUSTAINABLE THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY A BREWERY COULD
RETAIL CONSUMER BOTTLE WHAT WE
CALL GROWLERS. AND GET THEIR
WINERY TASTING ROOM COULD NOT.
THE DIRECTOR WOULD SUPPORTIVE
AND HELP THE TEAM THAT HE GAVE
ME ABOUT A PLAN FOR BRINGING US
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY- THE
RESTRICTION. AND END UP WITH
ONLY BECAUSE OF ONE.
PROHIBITING SUPPLIED BY. AT
EASY CHANGE ALL THE OCCURRED IN
PERMISSION TO STAY PERFECT IF
YOU HIRTY NINE BY ONE THING
LINE. IT'S EVEN BECOME MORE AND
JUSTIN ECONOMIC FROM THE PANDA.
IN MONTEREY COUNTY ALONE WE HAD
A LAYOFF OER SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE FR MARCH SIXTY FIVE
DAYS. NOW LIKE MANY OTHERS. IT
IS A STRUGGLE TO FIND TO GET RE.
ADD THE GROWTH OF WIND CHILLS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY KEEPS
CHANGING AND THE LAST FEW YEARS
THAT CROP YIELD HAD. BEEN AT
SOMETIME ABOUT DIDN'T SOMETIMES
AT THE LAST YEAR IN MONTEREY
COUNTY. NOT SO GREAT OUR GROWTH.
CONDITION IS WELL ALL THAT THE
DATA IS STILL HOLDING WE KNOW
THAT IN MY WRITING JOURNEY LAST
YEAR ALONE- CONTRACTUALLY 45%
OF OUR GREAT TEAM GET HARVESTED
FIRES. YOU SHOULD OPPORTUNITY
STILL CONSUMER SUPPLIED BOTTLES
HE IS NOT ONLY IMPORTANT FOR
OUR SMALL CAGE YOU RAN IT IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR RECOVERY AND
INCREASING DEMAND AND PROVIDING
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO MARKET
OUR WINE. THIS IS IT. OPTIONAL
FOR WINERIES AND IT IS ONLY FOR
WINERIES IT IS ONLY. WITH
LICENSED WE CALL THEM PEOPLE
CAN CHOOSE TO USE AND DUPLICATE
I WOULD CHOOSE NOT. AVAILABLE
TO OTHERS. FORWARD LOOKING TO
TAKE THAT MESSAGE STATE
MEASURES RELATE TO. CURB SO
YOU'RE THANK YOU MUCH FOR THIS
AND THE WINE INDUSTRY REALLY
NEEDS ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO HELP
THEM RECOVER FROM CALVIN AND I
HAVE TO ADD AND FROM WILDFIRES.
TOOL CREATED REDUCTION AND YOU
SHOULD GET GLAD ABOUT THE STATE
AND BRING GREATER ATTENTION TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF REDUCING AND
RECYCLING. WHICH IS ALIGNED
WITH WHAT THE STATEMENT TO DATE
THE TIRES. OFF THE HUB WINERY
BUILT DEEPER CONNECTIONS WITH
THEIR. COMMUNITIES AND BRING
THE WINE INDUSTRY IN. GREAT
BEER PARTNER. THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT I'M AVAILABLE TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING ALL OF YOU ON
AN EDUCATIONALTOUR OF MONTEREY
WINE COUNTRY WHENEVER YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU. DEBORAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I
AM LOOKING TO THE GALLERY TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY. FIFTEEN NON. WE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. DO
WE HAVE ANYONE IN ROOM TWELVE
WISHING TO TESTIFY. IT APPEARS
NOT. THEN WE WILL THEN COME
BACK TO THE MODERATOR.
MODERATOR CAN YOU ANNOUNCE TO
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
REMOTELY THAT WE WILL PROCEED
WITH THEIR TESTIMONY THEY WOULD
CONTACT YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK AN EIGHTY TWO
THIRTY NINE LONDON ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER IN PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. ON EIGHTY TWO
THIRTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
THEIR OWN NOW. AND IT IS
UNLIMITED HERE WE HAVE ONE
PERSON IN Q. CAN YOU PROCEED
THEN. WHAT A LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND I THINK HE NOW THE HELP OF
THE WINE INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY TWO THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU. AND AT THE TIME OF
THE DAY WE HAVE NO WE DON'T
THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT NO WE WILL
ASSUME THAT THEY THEN. DO NOT
WISH TO TESTIFY FURTHER THAT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO DO IS NOW
MODERATOR TO INQUIRE OF ANYONE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY. AN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY TWO THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH MY NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF. EIGHTY TWO THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN THERE-
NOW. WE SEE THAT AT THE TIME OF
DAY CARE WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY. COULD WE CHECK WITH
THE ROOM ONE ONE TWO TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY THERE TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION. NOT THANK YOU.
THEN WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED. OUR AUTHOR. THE
DEVELOPER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HAVE ANY. BUT ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AND CLOSE ON YOUR BILL
THE BELL. THE NUMBER OF THE
BILL WE HAVE A MOTION ON. NINE
HUNDRED BARGE YOU HAVE MOVED
THE BILL ARE YOU GOING TO SPEAK
ON THE BILL I COULD DO BOTH.
WELL I THINK WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
YOU DO WILL. I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND- THE AUTHOR THAT THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH THE ISSUE- THAT
SPANS THE STATE CERTAINLY- THE
INDUSTRY SO. GRADUALLY TO THE
OFFICE JUVENTUS FORWARD IF IT
MEETS WITH HIS APPROVAL I'D
LOVE TO. BE ADDED ON AS A AS A
JOINT OR CO AUTHOR OF SOME
SORT- IF THAT IS SATISFACTORY
TO YOU BUT TODAY I'LL BE PROUD
TO SUPPORT TO. THIS LEGISLATION
I THINK I THINK CENTER SURE.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR JONES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK THIS
IS MR VIA DO IS. FIRST BILL IN
THE SENATE THE CORRECT ANSWER
SO I WAS ENCOURAGED BY THE
SPEAKER IN FAVOR OF THE BILL ON
TAKING A TOUR- DOWN THE
MONTEREY AREA. AND SO I'M
THINKING MAYBE THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD HOLD THE BILL UNTIL WE
ARE ALL ABLE TO GET DOWN THERE
ON THAT TOUR. MAYBE THE FIRST
WEEK OF- OF OUR BREAK. THAT
WOULD PLEASE THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE. FINNERAN JOHN THAT
WOULD BE A VERY GOOD
SUGGESTIONS ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SIR. I WOULD ALSO- I'M ALREADY
ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR SO WE
SHOULD PROBABLY GO AND PASS THE
BILL TODAY. WE DON'T WANT TO
DELAY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THEN
WE WILL- ASCENDED TO THAT
MEMBERS ARE INDEED INVITED TO
MONTEREY COUNTY NOT UNDERSTAND
THE POTENCY AND THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO AFFECT THE ENTIRE.
WINE INDUSTRY. AND ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FIVE
HUNDRED PARDON TINA JUST JUST
FOR THE RECORD BEFORE WE
CELEBRATE THE BILL STILL HAS TO
GO TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SENATOR FORTINO
REMINDS US THIS BILL WILL ALSO
GO TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE CENTER.
AND MR MILLER TO A WOULD YOU
CARE TO. ADD ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AS TO THE MERITS OF
YOUR BILL THANK YOU CHAIR THANK
YOU SENATORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN ITEM. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
A MOTION TO DELIVER FOR US. WE
HAVE THE AUTHOR HAVING CLOSED
ALL TESTIMONY HAVING BEEN
COMPLETED. THE SECTOR WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YES THIS
IS OUR FINAL ITEM TO AB TWO
THIRTY NINE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TODD.
NELSON HIGH NELSON HI ALAN HI
ALAN ARCHULETA ARCHULETA EYED
BAKER I BAKER HI GORGEOUS HI
BORDERS HI BRADFORD. LATER
PLEASE R. I. WESO JOHN HI JOHN
HI KEN LONGER MELENDEZ POURED
INTO NOW. FOR NINETEEN OH FIVE
RUBIO WILL. RUBIO HI. THAT'S
NINE ZERO GERMAN NINE ZERO A
PLACE AT BILL AND CALLED BILL
CLINTON. PICKED IT UP YOU KNOW
YOU'VE DONE WELL ON YOUR FIRST
BILL SIR. WE WILL LET THE CALLS
LATER AND THEY WILL NOTIFY YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON THEN TO
OUR SECOND BILL DO WE HAVE A
SEPTEMBER YES WE HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER LIVING HERE A. B. ONE
FOUR ZERO THREE PLEASE PROCEED.
THE MUGSHOT SENATOR NIELSEN
AND- WALLS SURE GOD IS NOT HERE
I DID WANT TO EXPRESS MY SORROW
AND SYMPATHY TO HIM FOR HIS
CONSTITUENTS WHO- LAWFULLY
VACCINATED DID SUCCUMB TO CODE
NINETEEN THIS PAST WEEK I'M
VERY SORRY TO HEAR THAT. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS. AT FORTINO THREE
AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR TO
DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
DUE TO A PLANNED. THE ENERGY
STATION EVENT MEMBERS AS WE
KNOW UTILITIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE BEEN ISSUING PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS. AS A TOOL TO
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK DURING
WEATHER EVENTS WERE POORLY
MAINTAINED ELECTRICAL
TRANSMISSION LINES. COULD CAUSE
A WILDFIRE IN TWENTY NINETEEN A
SERIES OF MISMANAGING POORLY
PLANNED PS PS EVENTS IMPACTED
MILLIONS OF PG&E CUSTOMERS. AND
SENT STATE OFFICIALS SCRAMBLING
TO RESPOND TO NUMEROUS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY IMPACTS FROM
THE PLANNED POWER OUTAGE.
BECAUSE THE PS PS WAS A PLANNED
OUTAGE THE GOVERNOR HIMSELF WAS
FORCED TO WAIT. FOR OTHER
SYSTEMIC FAILURES TO OCCUR
BEFORE BEING ABLE TO DEPLOY
RESOURCES AND ASSIST
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
LITERALLY. LEFT IN THE DARK.
THIS IS. EIGHTY FORTY THREE
WILL INCREASE THE STATE'S
PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS BY GIVING
THE GOVERNOR EXPLICIT AUTHORITY
TO DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
RESULTING FROM A PS PS EVENT.
AND ALLOW THE STATE TO PRE
DEPLOY RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
PROTECT HEALTH SAFETY AND
PROPERTY OF RESIDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THIS YEAR'S
WILDFIRE SEASON IS ALREADY
UNDERWAY AND IS EXPECTED TO BE
ONE OF THE WORST IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. EIGHTY FORTY THREE IS
AN ESSENTIAL PART OF OUR
BROADER WILDFIRE PREVENTION
EFFORTS THAT WILL HELP PROTECT
PROPERTY AND LIVES THIS FIRE
SEASON AND FOR FIRE SEASONS TO
COME. THIS MEASURE HAS RECEIVED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND
INCLUDES AN URGENCY CLAUSE SO
THIS TOOL CAN BE USED THIS FIRE
SEASON. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THE
FAMILY MEMBER. A. B. FOURTEEN
ALL THREE. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO SUPPORT I
SEE NONE IN THE GALLERY CAN WE
CHECKED WITH ROOM ONE ONE TWO.
APPEARS THAT ARE NOT ON THEIR
PRESENT. MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE- NOTIFY THE PUBLIC THAT
THE LINE WOULD BE OPEN TO THEM.
WHERE THEY'D LIKE TO GET IN
QUEUE TO TESTIFY. ON A V.
FOURTEEN OF. THREE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN OH
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOURTEEN OH THREE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW. THE
MOMENT AT YOUR END TO GATHER
THOSE LINE NUMBERS. THE SECOND
ONE MOMENT. MAINLINE YEAH IF WE-
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT SURE WAS
STILL GATHERING ALL MY NUMBERS.
LIE NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MODERATOR
THANK YOU POLITE NUMBER EIGHTY
YES SIR DEFINITELY CHAT LINE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION ON
THE BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY IN
FRANCE- WE JUST SAW THE AMOUNTS
THAT ARE BEING ADOPTED BY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY WE DO HAVE A
VERY VERY VERY MAJOR CONCERNS
WITH THE IMPLICATIONS THAT
COULD RESULT FROM THOSE.
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE BEEN CALLING
LOCAL PS YES MERCHANTS EACH AS
A COUNTIES- IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY OF
THEM SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS WE DON'T THINK IT'S
INTENT IS TO IMPOSE ANY
RESTRICTIONS. ON LOCAL
AUTHORITY TO CALL PST PST
ACCIDENTS IN THE FUTURE BUT
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT AND
MAKE SURE THAT IS NOT THE CASE
AND I WILL NOT BE THE IMPACT
FROM FORTINO. THREE GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. SHE TIMES
THAT HERE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR
ME. ST YOU HAVE NOBODY ELSE IN
Q. YES THERE NO ONE I THINK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. I SEE NONE IN THE
GALLERY CAN WE CHECK IN ROOM
TWELVE SHE NO ONE THERE.
MODERATOR ANYONE IN Q. TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FOURTEEN OH THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND TAKE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF A. B.
FOURTEEN OH THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIRMAN WE DO
HAVE SOMEONE KEEPING UP. THE
FEDERAL MEMBER LEVIN DO YOU DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS AS TO
THE- AMENDMENTS YOU'RE
PROPOSING TODAY. AND DO YOU
INTEND TO ACCEPT THOSE AS
AUTHOR CEMENT YES THAT'S RIGHT
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHURCH AS I STATED IN THE
BEGINNING OF MY- MY-
PRESENTATION- IBM BY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS- AND I THINK A VERY
IMPORTANT PART IN POINT TO MAKE
PARTICULARLY TO. WITNESSES
TESTIMONY TODAY IS THAT MY BILL
AS IT WAS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED
IN AS IT WAS PASSED OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY INCLUDE BOTH LOCAL
EVENTS AND LOCAL STATES OF
EMERGENCY. AND A STATE
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE WHO HAS AUTHORED
SB FIFTY TWO IN THIS COMMITTEE
HAS VOTED ON SB FIFTY TWO
ALREADY. HIS BILL FOCUSES ON
THE LOCAL EMERGENCY AND SO WE
NEGOTIATED THAT MY BILL WILL
FOCUS ON THE STATEWIDE- OR THE
STATE'S ABILITY THE GOVERNOR'S
ABILITY I DON'T SEE HER
EMERGENCY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AND I SEE NO MICROPHONES UP TO
ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONSCOMMENTS. THERE WE
ARE IN THE BACK THIS LETTER TO
GLACIER HAPPY TO MOVE IT
ABILITY FOR EVERY TIME A SECURE
IN ROOM. PARDON. THE IN. A
CHAMBER MEMBER WHAT DID YOU
HAVE A ANOTHER LEAD WITNESS ON
THIS. BILL YEAH THERE WERE TWO
WITNESSES I BELIEVE WE DID HEAR
FROM JOHN KENNEDY FROM RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES I
BELIEVE WE ALSO HAVE ONE FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES- JULIA HALL-
THAT HAD BEEN- I DISSIPATED BY
THE MODERATOR. DID ANYBODY ELSE
THE MODERATOR IN Q. I AM ON THE
LINE BUT I COULD KNOCK YOU OUT
THIS IS JULIA HOLIDAY VACATION
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WERE ON THE
LIST DIDN'T TESTIFY WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JULIE HALL AT THE
DIVISION OF CALIFORNIA ARE YOU
CAN CAN WE ARE AT FOURTEEN AT
THREE REALLY I THINK THE POWER
SHUT OFF AND- IN OCTOBER TWENTY
NINETEEN GOVERNOR NIXON
DECLARED A STATEWIDE EMERGENCY
DUE TO THE FACT THAT HIGH WIND
EVENT. EVENTS THAT RESULTED IN
FIRES AND EVACUATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE. CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTOR OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES HAVE IMPLEMENTED YES
YES AND THEN. HELP ENSURE THEIR
CLINIC DOES NOT START A
WILDFIRE HE DID AND CAN LEAVE
MANY CRITICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
INCLUDING WATER AND WASTEWATER
AGENCIES WITHOUT POWER FOR DAYS
AT A TIME. DURING THESE EVENTS
WATER AND WASTE WATER PROVIDERS
INCREASE SIGNIFICANT UNBUDGETED
COSTS TO ENSURE CONTINUED WATER
AND WASTEWATER SERVICES
PROVIDED CENTRAL PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY SERVICES. THE
CALIFORNIA VERSION TWO SERVICES
ACT PROVIDES THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN BE REIMBURSED FOR
PERSONNEL COSTS QUITMAN COSTS
AND THE COST OF SUPPLIES
MATERIALS. USED DURING DISASTER
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES ENCOURAGE
WHEN IT EMERGES CLAIMED. UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE ANNOTATION
EVENTS ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
LIST OF CONDITIONS THAT
CONSTITUTE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. THEREFORE COSTS
ACCRUED DURING AN EVENT DO NOT
QUALIFY THE BILL WOULD HELP
REMEDY THAT ISSUE BY ADDING
PLANNED THE EDUCATION EVENT BUT
WITH THE CONDITION. WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE FOLLOWING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT THIS
MORNING AND THANK. YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MESSAGE HERE WE DO
HAVE PEOPLE TO SPEAK OPPOSITION
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. WHEN YOU
PROCEED WITH YOUR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
SAID MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I DID ENOUGH
LEMMINGS ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY-
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO OPPOSE AB
FORTINO THREE- WHILE PG&E
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT.
TO ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
SEEK REIMBURSEMENT FOR COSTS
INCURRED FROM RUNNING EMERGENCY
OPERATION CENTERS DURING PS PSP
BENT. WE BELIEVE AT FOURTEEN OH
THREE WHICH HINDER P. GENIES
ABILITY TO SEE COST RECOVERY
FOR OPERATION AND RECOVERY
DURING THIS TIME AND THEN-
EXITED BY THE EXPEDITED COST
RECOVERY ALLOWS US. TO
CONTINUOUSLY RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES WHILE LIMITING THE
IMPACT TO ITS BASE OPERATIONS
INCLUDING SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDING PORTABLE SERVICE- BY
MAKING A PS PSP BENT AND
EMERGENCY THIS BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BLOCK. R. P. G. P.
G. ANY USE OF THE EXPEDITED
COST RECOVERY MECHANISMS AND
COULD FORCE US TO RELY ON OTHER
COST RECOVERY MECHANISMS THAT
CAN TAKE YEARS TO COMPLETE-
AGAIN WE- SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY THEN HE TO.
DO THESE ACTIVITIES HOWEVER- WE
MUST OPPOSE. AB FOURTEEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. ONE MORE
REMINDER PLEASE RETURN AS A
REMINDER PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
LAURA CARLA THIRTY CALIFORNIA
AND THEN IN A COUPLE DIFFERENT
DEMANDED A WHILE HE AGREES WITH
THE BILL'S INTENDED TO PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL RETURNS TO STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RESPOND TO
PIA PIA THANKS WITHOUT CHANGES
TO ADDRESS CERTAIN AND I'M
INTENDED CONSEQUENCES-
EMERGENCY DECLARATION FOR PS
TEETH COULD TRIGGER SEVERAL
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
INTENDED FOR MAJOR DISASTERS-
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT- BUT THERE
COULD BE A BANK AND- THE FIRST
BEING. THAT TYPE OF AMENDMENT.
TO BETTER ALIGN WITH. THE FIFTY
TWO YEAR FOR THOSE RETURN OF
THE REMAINING POSTMARKS THEN IT
YOU. BLIND TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CAN MAKE ME CLEAN AND THEN IT'S
ATTENDING ON GAS AND ELECTRIC
ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ACT
TO REMOVE THE TERMS THAT THE
ANNOTATION EVENT FROM
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION- EIGHT
FIVE FIVE EIGHT THE END
RECOUNTED IN TWO EIGHT FIVE
FIVE EIGHT HE FOR THE REASON
BEING THAT IT WOULD TRIGGER THE
PC. REGULATIONS THAT ARE
INTENDED FOR MAJOR CATCH CATCH
CATCH YOUR FEES- IN SUPPORT OF
CUSTOMER THAN THAT WITHOUT
GIVING UP THAT WOULD CREATE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN COSTS
YEAH WE APPRECIATE THE OTHER
CONCERNS WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH HIM. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE. LOOKING UP IN
THE COMPUTER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. IN THAT. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE NO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. RIGHT BUT
CANADA JONES HAS HIS MICROPHONE
UP SENATOR JONES WILL COMING
BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- MR LEVINE I'M REALLY
CONFLICTED. IN A MINUTE M. I'M
IN AN AREA OF THE STATE WHERE
YEAH MY DISTRICT IS SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THESE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS. AND YOU KNOW MY AREA
THE UTILITIES I THINK DONE A
PRETTY DECENT JOB OF. PREPARING
THEIR FACILITIES AND YOU HAVE
WEATHER STATIONS ALL OVER MY
DISTRICT- BUT TO PUT THE IT
CREATES AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN
WHEN WE MAKE THIS A STATE OF
EMERGENCY ON PS P. S. IT
CREATES AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN ON
THE OTHER RATE PAYERS-
SOMEBODY'S PAYING THE BILL AND
SO SOMEBODY'S GETTING TWELVE
MONTHS OFF OF PAYING THEIR
THEIR BUILDINGS YOU KNOW. THE
OTHER REPAIRS ARE MAKING THAT
UP. AND SO. I GUESS THE
QUESTION WOULD BE IS AS A PS PS
YOU'VE BEEN. WHY WOULD A PS PS
EVENT DESIGNED TO PREVENT
WILDFIRES NECESSITATE THE SAME
TWELVE MONTH LONG RESPONSE AS
AN EMERGENCY EVENT SUCH AS A
FIRE OR EARTHQUAKE. OR FLOOD
EVEN AND AS I SAID IS IT THE
SWITCHES IT SHIFTS THE COSTS OF
THE OTHER REPAIRS. YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR JONES FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND- AND I DO
AGREE WITH YOU THAT- THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME ACTORS SOME SOME
UTILITIES THAT HAVE PERFORMED
BETTER OVER THE PAST DECADE TO
PREPARE THEMSELVES FOR- THE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT
NOW THAN OTHERS. THE
DISTINCTION ISN'T- IT. IT I
THINK THAT YOU MEET TO SOON TO-
AND THIS ISN'T A CRITICISM OF
YOU I THINK IT'S EASY EASY
MAKE- ABOUT THESE DOWNSTREAM
IMPACTS. PARTICULARLY ON- SOME
RATE FREEZES- THAT ARE. NOT
THAT MANY STEPS HAVE TO BE MADE
TO GET TO THAT THE FIRST IS OF
COURSE WE ARE ONLY MAKING PS PS
EVENTS AT AN EVENT THAT COULD
POSSIBLY BE DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY BY A GOVERNOR IF THAT
GOVERNOR DETERMINES THAT THAT
IS NECESSARY BY THE EVENT AND
THE- CASCADING EVENTS AFFECTED
BY THAT EVENT SO GOVERNORS
DON'T CALL STATES OF EMERGENCY
**** NILLY- ON AT ALL AND I
WOULD GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF MOST
RECENTLY OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
DECLARATIONS OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AROUND A DROUGHT.
WHERE HE VERY QUICKLY ARE NOT
VERY QUICKLY BUT BUT- EARLIER
DECLARED THAT TWO COUNTIES
WE'RE IN A DROUGHT AND HAD A
STATE OF EMERGENCY MEDICINE- IN
SEDONA TWO COUNTIES OF WHICH-
MARIN RECEIVES WATER FROM-
BESIDES OUR OWN LOCAL
RESERVOIRS MARIN COUNTY HAS
DECLARED ITSELF IN A DROUGHT
BUT YET THE GOVERNOR HAS NOT
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
IN MARIN SO THAT'S YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BIT OF A ANALOGY OF
GOVERNORS DO WITH THEIR OWN
COURSE OF DETERMINATION TO GET
TO A VERY SERIOUS- NAMING OF
WHETHER OR NOT SOMETHING IS A
STATE OF EMERGENCY SO I WOULD
IMAGINE. THAT IF THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT COST RECOVERY ISSUE
FOR EXAMPLE- IF WE WANT WANTED
TO RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDS
BECAUSE OF SOME EVENT TRIGGERED
BY A P. S. P. S. THAT MIGHT BE
WHERE A GOVERNOR WOULD BE
STEPPING. IN IF THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT COST ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE CALL.
CENTER RUBIO. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- AND I WANT TO JUST-
TO SHARE SOME OF MY CONCERNS
BUT IT'S NOT SO MUCH. ABOUT THE
BILL BUT I HAD TALKED TO THE
AUTHOR AND I'VE HAD VERY FEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO SIT DOWN WITH
HIM AND TALK TO HIM ABOUT THAT
THE NUANCES OF THE SPELL I KNOW
THAT P. S. P. S. VENTS HAVE
BEEN CATASTROPHIC AND SO MANY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND I CAN
SEE WHY THIS BILL IS NEEDED
BUT- THERE'S A FEW CONCERNS AND
I WANTED JUST TO STAY FOR THE
RECORD THAT I. NEED A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME FOR RESEARCH
SINCE WE JUST TRANSITIONED FROM
IBM AND OF HEALTH OF ORIGIN AND
THIS NEEDS A LITTLE BIT MORE
VETTING AND MY PERSONAL OPINION
FOR ME PERSONALLY BUT I WILL
SUPPORT IT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYMORE MEMBERS
WISHING TO ASK QUESTIONS OR
TESTIFY WE HAVE ASSEMBLED A
CENTER GLACIER. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- IT
SEEMS I MEAN I ALSO HAVE A
DISTRICT THAT'S- HAS STRUGGLED
THROUGH THESE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS IN AND A PART OF THIS
BILL AND SO MANY OTHER BILLS
THAT WE HAVE DEALT WITH IN THE
SPACES TO CRY TO CREATE. THE
INCENTIVE MOTIVATION WHATEVER
YOU WANNA CALL IT FOR THE
UTILITIES TO HARDEN THEIR
SYSTEMS IN A WAY THAT- VOICE
THESE EVENTS EVEN HAPPENING I
MEAN THAT'S REALLY THE GOAL
HERE SO I RECOGNIZE THERE MIGHT
BE SOME POTENTIAL BURDEN. ON
UTILITIES FROM THIS LEGISLATION
THAT'S IT FOR ME IT SEEMS LIKE
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IT
PROVIDES AN OPTION FOR THE
GOVERNOR HE CONTINUES OUR OUR
WORK TO TRY TO CREATE THESE
DISINCENTIVES TO NOT INVEST IN
THAT COST MONEY FOR TO RATE
PAYERS TO THESE EVENTS COST
MONEY- SO WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
WORK- YOU KNOW. FOR THE BOAT IN
THE RIGHT IN THE SAME DIRECTION
MAYBE IN IN DIFFERENT WAYS BUT
I THINK THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT.
WITH THAT AND HAPPY TO MOVE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO COMMENT. SHADING
NINE THEN. THERE SHOULD BE A
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO THEN
GIVE US A FINAL PLUNGE. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU TO ALL THE SENATORS
FOR THE THOUGHTFUL DIALOGUE AND
CONVERSATION SENATOR GLAZER
ESENTIALLY GAVE MY CLOTHES-
BEAUTIFULLY SAID THE POINT IS
NOT NEVER TO HAVE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY NEVER EVEN HAVE A P.
S. . S. THE POINT IS TO HAVE.
AN INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE CAN BE
CONFIDENT THAT- WE CAN TURN ON
THE LIGHTS KEEP THE FOOD IN OUR
REFRIGERATOR- COLD AS IT'S
NEEDED. AND IN IN IN HI WEATHER
EVENTS NO THAT- OUR OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL NOT FAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION RESPECT ASPIRIN I
GO. DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SENATOR BLASIER RELATIONSHIP
HAND FOR THE MOTION TO PASS. WE
WILL HAVE THE SECTOR CALL THE
ROLL IT HAS BEEN MOVED THE
AUTHOR HAS ADOPTED THE
AMENDMENTS- AND WE CAN PROCEED
NOW WITH THE FIRST ROLL CALL.
BUSINESS FILE ITEM SIX AB
FOURTEEN OH THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED BE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOT
MILTON. ALAN HI ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ARCHULETA I'D
BETTER BUY BECKER HI GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD LATER HI PLEASE R.
IGHT WESO JONES CATALOGUER
MELENDEZ ACCORDING TO NOW I
WANT TO KNOW I. RUBIO. RUBIO HI
WELCOME TO. THAT'S SIX ZERO
GERMAN. THE VOTERS SIX ZERO WE
WILL PLACE THE BILL ON CALL WE
HAVE YET OTHER BILLS AND WE'RE-
DELIGHTED AND CALLED THE- THAT
THE CALLS A LITTLE LATER FAMILY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS.
OKAY. WE NOW HAVE DO WE HAVE
OUR NEXT ALTER THE CHEERS WE DO.
THE NEXT BILL IS FILE ITEM
SEVEN A. B. ONE FIVE SEVEN
FOUR. ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOSER
RETREAT REFRESH WILL BE
PRESENTING THE BILL ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHOW BACK TO
H. PLEASE PROCEED FAMILY MEMBER
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS-
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR IS A
COMMITTEE BILL FROM THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE IT
ENHANCES THE ABILITY OF THE
STATE TO PROSECUTE FRAUDULENT
CONTRACTING ACTIVITY INCREASES
COLLABORATION AMONG SMALL
BUSINESS AND D. V. B. E.
ADVOCATES AND PROVIDES MORE
TARGETED SUPPORT TOOL WARDING
DEPARTMENTS IN ACHIEVING SMALL
BUSINESS AND TV B. E.
PROCUREMENT PARTICIPATION GOALS.
ISSUES ADDRESSED IN THE BILL
WERE DEVELOPED THROUGH
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENTS
DISCUSSIONS WITH STATE
CONTRACTING STAFF AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN STATE AUDIT.
OF THE D. V. B. E. PROCUREMENT
PROGRAM. WITH ME TODAY- OUR
NUMBER OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
INCLUDING FELLOW VERMAELEN COAL
FROM THE COALITION FOR SMALL
AND DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESSES. AND SLASHER
BARRICADE ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU. DO DO DO YOU HAVE YOUR
FIRST WITNESS A MODERATOR CAN
YOU PUT THE FIRST WITH MAX.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THERE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS PHIL VERMAELEN I
REPRESENT A COALITION OF SMALL
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESSES WHY
SHOULD TO THE SITUATION AS WELL.
MISS U. ZERO I'M STRONG SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE- I SIT ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
SMALL BUSINESS ADVISORY TASK
FORCE. AND THIS MEASURE
CONTAINS MANY PROVISIONS IN IT
THAT- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT FOR
EXAMPLE- ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
WHICH ARE THE BACKBONE OF CITY
CALIFORNIA HAVE. REACHING OUT
TO THE VARIOUS STATE AGENCIES
DEPARTMENTS AND BUREAUS THAT
ARE A LEADING CONTRACTS AND
TRYING TO ASCERTAIN INFORMATION
TO HELP THEM. PARTICIPATE IN
THE BIDDING PROCESS- THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE WILL WORK TO
DEVELOP A LIST OF- LIAISONS
WITH ALL OF THE STATE AGENCIES
SO THAT THESE SMALL BUSINESSES
WILL HAVE A RESOURCE TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS TO FIND OUT THAT
SHIPPING INFORMATION. ANOTHER
INTERESTING IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS BILL IS DEALING WITH A
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE IS- YOU KNOW THERE
ARE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
D. V. D. V. POTENTIAL
BUSINESSES THAT COULD BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE SMALL
BUSINESS PROGRAMS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER THEY
HAVE DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS TO
BE PROPERLY NEED AND AGAIN- THE
SMALL OUT MORE WITH THE D. V.
B. E. ADVOCATE. THEY WILL BE
WORKING ON DEVELOPING ACCESS
FOR OUT REACH FOR THESE- VERY
EXPEDIENCY'S. OTHER BIG PROBLEM
HAS BEEN THE GAMING OF THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE- PLEASE PROTECT
PREFERENCE PROGRAMS IN PLACE
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF BIGGER
AGE. THE BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN GAMING THE SYSTEM BY
PROVIDING- SMALL BUSINESSES UP
2% PASS THROUGH FOR EXAMPLE. SO
THAT THEY CAN ENABLE THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SMALL
BUSINESS PREFERENCE PROGRAMS WE
HAVE TO STOP THIS IT IS GAMING
THE SYSTEM FOR BILLY AND- THERE
ARE. NOW THROUGH THIS MEASURE
THAT WILL PROVIDE ACCESS TO GO
AFTER THESE PEOPLE THEY'RE IN
THE BAD ACTORS IN THE PROGRAM
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT.
FINALLY THERE'S A PROVISION IN
THE TARGET AREA CONTACT
PREFERENCES ACCESS. THE
CONTAINS TWO PROVISIONS AND IT
WONDERS WORKSITE THING
COURAGE'S- BUSINESSES TO LOCATE
THEIR BUSINESSES IN. DISTRESSED
AREAS OF THE STATE THERE'S
ANOTHER PROVISION THAT- A
LITTLE TOWARDS A PREFERENCE.
FOR HIRING FROM THOSE AREAS
HOWEVER IT IS NEVER BEEN
CLARIFIED PROPERLY AND THIS
MEASURE WILL CLARIFY THAT THERE
IS UP TO A FIVE PERCENT.
PREFERENCE FOR HIRING PEOPLE
FROM THESE DISTRESSED AREAS
COMBINE THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BILL THAT I URGE ALL
MEMBERS TO SUPPORT WITH THAT.
HIGHER DRIVER THANK YOU. BACK
TO- TO BE MOON. DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER. SURE PRINCIPLES WITH
BRITISH. BETTER OKAY THANK YOU
ACTUALLY THE AUTHOR NODDING. IN
THE GALLERY. SENATOR ROBERT
YOUR MICROPHONES UP. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT- WELL FIRST I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS
RIVAS FOR PRESENTING ON ON
BEHALF IN AN ABSENT MEMBER BACK
I THINK THIS IS JUST A GOOD
MEASURE NOT ONLY DOES IT HELP
ROOT OUT BAD ACTORS BUT ALSO IT
DOES ENCOURAGE HIRING IN
DISTRESSED AREAS SO WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
WHEN APPROPRIATE THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION. TO CASH. NOBODY
IN THE GALLERY AND WHILE ONE
TWELVE DO WE HAVE ANYONE ONE
TWELVE ALL. BUT SENATOR OUR
CHILDREN YEAH THANK YOU MR AS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE MEDIA
MILITARY VETERANS COMMITTEE AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND IT IS DISABLED VETERANS
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE. THAT WE
MUST PROTECT AND PROTECT OUR
DISABLED VETERANS AND VETERANS
WHO DO GO INTO SMALL BUSINESSES
AND BEGAN TO BE PART OF THE
ECONOMY- AND SO IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT WE REALIZE THAT THIS
IS A WAY TO PROTECT THOSE
VETERANS AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
CONTRACTS THAT ARE AWARDED TO
VETERANS. ARE LOOKED AT BEDDED
AND FOR VETERANS AND THEIR
PROTECTION AND- I THINK THAT-
THIS IS A GREAT BILL AND I'D-
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE ALL OF US
TO SUPPORT IT AND I THINK THAT-
THE BETTORS COMMUNITY VERY
PROUD WITH THAT SUPPORT WITH
THAT I URGE THE IBOOK. THANK
YOU GENDER ARCHULETA. ANY OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. J. NINE. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN Q. MODERATOR. I
THINK YOU GET THE CARE YOU
DON'T MINDIF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A B. FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THERE ARE NOW. AT THE
TIME OF THE GERMAN WE HAVE NO
ONE Q. HAVING NO FURTHER
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION. THE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR OPPOSITION.
I SEE NONE IN THE GALLERY. ONE
TWELVE AND THEN I WILL GO BACK
TO THE MODERATOR. J. NINE
MODERATOR DID YOU MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ABC FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION A BABY. FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO NOW. AND AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
MONEY TO YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL
THEN PROCEED. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO GIVE US A CLOSING COMMENT.
FAMILY MEMBER REFRESH. THIS
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIVEAU. THE MOTION HAS BEEN
MADE FOR A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION DECEMBER MEMBER
REQUEST A. B. ONE FIVE SEVEN
FOUR. CHAPTER COULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
DOT. WE'LL SEND HI NOTHING HI
ALAN HI. HI ARCHULETA HI OR TO
LET ICE BREAKER ALL RIGHT BAKER
HI FORGES ALL RIGHT BORDERS I
BRADFORD LATER HI PLEASE R. I.
WESO JONES. CAN LONGER MELENDEZ
POURED INTO NOW HI FORTINO I
RUBIO RUBIO I WILL WELCOME HI.
THAT'S NINE ZERO SEVEN NINE
ZERO WE'LL PLACE AT BILL ON
CALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. DISH
WOULD CONCLUDE OUR AGENDA WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS ON CALL.
AND WE ARE AWAITING THE RETURN
OF THE CHAIR THE SHOW WE WILL
PUT THINGS ON HOLD. UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS A CARICATURE THAN WE
YEAH.
SECRETARY WOULD YOU BE SO KIND
AS TO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CALL. I ACTUALLY GOT A CHAIR.
RIGHT NOW I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND LIST THE CALLS I BELIEVE
THAT THE CHAIR WILL BE HERE
SHORTLY. THE SECRETARY WOULD
YOU LISTEN TO CALLS. COMMENCING
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO
THREE NINE. CAN WE DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST. PARDON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST. YES
AND I THINK CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR FIRST AND THAT WOULD BE THE.
810-838-6918. NINE FIVE SEVEN.
EIGHT THREE ONE TWO NINE WALK
HER LEASH WILL BE THE ROLL
NUMBERS. ON THAT CONSENT CAL
OKAY MEMBERS THIS IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBER
STODDARD BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
WENT SO I WEAR SO I CAN LONGER
I CAN WATER HI MELINDA'S RUBIO
HI RUBIO HI. THAT'S THIRTY ZERO
CHAIRMAN PUT IT ON CALL THEY
WILL MOVE TO CALL AN- AND PLACE
A CALL. THE NEXT BILL THAT WE
WOULD. PROCEED TO THE OTE ON
DAN WOULD BE A. B. TWO THREE
NINE ON CALL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TO AB TWO THREE NINE ABSENT
MEMBERS TODD BRADFORD. BRADFORD
I WENT SO I WAS SO I CAN LONGER
I CAN LONGER I KNOW WINDOWS
WILL. WELCOME HI. PLEASE CALL.
NEXT WE HAVE A B. ONE FOUR OH
THREE. THIS IS FOR A LOT OF
NUMBER SIX AB FORTINO THREE
ABSENT MEMBERS TODD NELSON ALL
RIGHT. SO. THIS IS A B. FORTINO
THREE TO ARRANGE. NELSON.
VERGES BRADFORD. WESSEL WETZEL
HI JONES CAN LONGER I REMEMBER
I'D MELENDEZ WELL. THAT'S EIGHT
ZERO CHAIRMAN THIS PLACE CALLED.
LAST YEAR. FIVE ONE SEVEN YES
OKAY IS THIS FALL I'M SEVEN A.
B. FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR ABSENT
MEMBERS THE NET DOT. HI DON HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I'D WESSELS
WESSELS LYING JONES CAN WATER
HI YOUR MOTHER HI MELENDEZ. AT
THIRTEEN ZERO GERMAN. THIRTEEN
ZERO BILL IS PASSED AND WE HAVE
OUR CHAIR HERE NOW. THEN WE
WOULD PROCEED THEN. TO THE BOAT.
WE WILL HAVE A
RESEARCH BRIEFLY. MEMBERS WHO
HAVE VOTED CAN DEPART.
WE'LL BE
GIVEN A SECOND SECRETARY
CLEARED UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE.
OKAY MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CALENDAR APPS AND I'M
GONNA. I GET IT- OKAY MEMORY
MATTERS. THIS IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS DODD.
AFTER NUMBERS DOT ON THE
CONSENT BY. DOT HI MELENDEZ.
THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO CHAIRMAN
OF THOSE OUT. FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT. NOW WILL MOVE
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO- A. B.
TWO THIRTY NINE SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE IN A B.
TWO THIRTY NINE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
NINE ABSENT MEMBER STARTED BY
DOT HI MELENDEZ. THAT'S
FOURTEEN ZERO GERMAN THE BILLS
OUT. US SECRETARY ARE WE MOVING
OUT FILE OUT OF NUMBER SIX.
OKAY LET'S DO THAT AB FORTINO
THREE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE HI
THIS IS PAUL ITEM NUMBER SIX A.
B. FORTINO THREE ABSENT MEMBERS
DADA HI DOT HI NELSON. FORGES
BRADFORD JONES NO JONES NO
CATALOGUER I'M SORRY I'M NOT A
MELINDA'S. WELCOME THAT IS.
THAT'S NINETY ONE THAT'S NINE
ONE THAT BUILDS OUT- VIOLATED
NUMBER SEVEN AB FIFTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR SECTOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE ON FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR THAT HAS FALLEN NUMBER
SEVEN A. B. FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR ABSENT MEMBERS JONES I.
DON'T HI MELENDEZ. FOURTEEN
ZERO THAT THAT WAS OUT. OKAY
THAT- CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
THANKS TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARKED JUST PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO OUR
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY THE
FISHEL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR PATIENT
COOPERATION- WEAVING COOK
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA I WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF HERE- THE-
OPERATOR AND- THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION IS A JERK.